welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of marvel's
what if episode nine what if the watcher
broke his oath a season finale that
assembles the guardians of the
multiverse to avenge vegas
as always this episode was filled with
interesting details and connections to
the live action mcu with major
implications for the multiverse going
forward so i'm gonna break it all down
frame by frame for everything that you
might have missed we open with captain
carter after her jump to the present era
in episode 1 following in the footsteps
of steve rogers and the lumerian star
mission from the opening of captain
america winter soldier peggy now wears
the blue and white stealth suit that
steve wore but with a union jack pattern
across the chest instead and natasha has
a shorter haircut that she had in that
film their target is once again batroc
except before it was rumlow briefing
everyone how many pirates
top mercs led by this guy
george batrock peggy leads this briefing
how many pirates 20 or so charmers led
by this one batroc in the film we later
learned that nick fury actually hired
batroc to hijack the lumerian star
because he was suspicious of shield's
true intentions for project insight and
he secretly ordered natasha to steal
data from those computers you know i'm
getting a little tired of being a
furious janitor relax it's not that
complicated so now peggy leading the
briefing suggests that this is her
mission not yuri's operation which might
be why the cargo is different from
project insight related stuff as we
learned the post-credits scene her steve
rogers old hydro stomper armor with
someone inside we could see biometrics
over on the left so that someone is
alive but assuming shield was still
being corrupted by hydra at this point
this hydro stomper could have been part
of hydra's winter soldier program since
if you think about it steve did kinda
take bucky's place back in episode 1 and
it would be one way of explaining how
steve survived this long setting up poor
peggy in this awkward conflict now with
steve rogers in a kind of iron lung
brainwashed by hydra now we hear the
variant capture carter theme from
episode one gentlemen watch our six
strike team you heard the captain gear
up this episode is actually great with
musical light motifs including a piano
rendition of steve's theme and there's
someone inside
the guardians theme
stay here
leave this fight to us killmonger's
theme
doctor strange's theme
and the avengers theme
just as natasha tried to hook up steve
with kristen from statistics natasha
does the same with peggy you know
bernard in accounting was asking about
you nothing good has ever followed the
phrase bernard in accounting poor
bernard accountants make great partners
peggy nothing good has ever followed the
phrase bernard in accounting
especially bernard is adam bernard
brashear blue marble because if so you
gotta get on that but natasha says what
if his name was steve
ouch just when we were becoming pals
widow yeah peggy is still sore over
never getting that dance with steve
rogers which she brings up again when
she tells batroc she's a pretty good
dancer and when peggy catches her shield
it kicks off a little puff of vapor
slicing through the night air and in
this thick sea layer with eyes gleaming
to match the bright full moon is the
watcher captain carter the soldier lost
in time you have been chosen so yes the
watcher is recruiting the dream team to
save the multiverse that comes from what
if number 39 what if the watcher saved
the universe in which he forms a team
consisting of thor an android iron man
dr doom from the fantastic five and
vampire wolverine and from this week
kaleidoscope wipe over to the dairy
queen in missouri from episode 2 as well
as the guardians volume 2 film and here
we see ego linking with peter quill to
form the expansion from that film but
t'challa's ship then mandela actually
leads the other ravagers ship in the
strike and ego says relax son it'll all
be over in a thousand years or so just a
reminder of ego's plan in that film to
use quill as a thousand year battery i
wanted to do this together
that i suppose you'll have to learn by
spending the next thousand years as a
battery and then on to nidavellir of
course the weapons forgery from infinity
war where gamora is carrying thanos's
double-bladed sword and wears the armor
that she wore in 2014 in in-game as well
as etre and tony stark and the
hulkbuster armor with sakara decor the
three of them melty in the infinity
gauntlet i really wanted it to do a t2
thumbs up on the way down but apparently
this is the aftermath of an episode that
was delayed to season 2 which would have
shown gamora killing thanos on sakaar
they say it was delayed because of kovid
i call producing animation
remotely it's not like trying to do live
action remotely they totally could have
got it done there was some plot reason
that they delayed it i'm telling you i
think this plot would have involved tony
stark in age of ultron hulkbuster armor
taking hulk's place on the quinjet to
sakhar and maybe thanos sacrificing
nebula on vermeer instead of gamora so
that peter quill didn't stupidly break
his trance and they could have stopped
thanos earlier another possibility is
that stark could have gotten stuck on
the other side of that wormhole in the
first avengers film when he nuked thanos
forces and then maybe got stranded on
sakhar and had to build that hulkbuster
armor from scratch and a dump with a
pile of scraps now notice each still has
his hands whereas in the main mcu
continuity thanos cut off his hands
right after he forged that gauntlet that
they are currently melting and casts the
stumps in uru so something changed maybe
they used a reality stone to bring his
hands back before pulverizing the stones
with the infinity crusher or the
animators didn't give a now tony's
armor has some upgrades including some
huge discs on the shoulders maybe these
are the sonic cannons from his designs
that were used to subdue hulk in the
2008 film and were actually later added
to his drones and spider-man far from
home also there are three claws on each
fist
did tony run into wolverine is that why
this episode was delayed in season two
oh my god but this would have been the
one episode this season to spare tony
stark's life and here he says how do we
put a suit of armor around the world
around the galaxy you can't tell me
there's not another big bad lurking in
the shadows monster under the bed always
with that suit of armor it's like his
only metaphor now gamora sees this big
bad as the watcher reflected in tony's
securian plating but i think this line
was added to redirect this delayed
episode as one setting up the season 1
finale to instead one connected to
season 2 and whatever season 2's new
multiversal big bad will be now while
kang seems like a good bet i think the
other watchers with whom watu made his
oath and now broke that oath coming to
seek accountability could also be the
possible new big bad shuri and pepper
lead the dormilage against killmonger
from episode six pepper wielding that
gun that looks like the one based on the
asgardian destroyer armor that coulson
wielded in the first avengers film and
shuri wielding her vibranium gauntlets
from black panther weaponizing those
alongside a refusal to get vaccinated
the watcher recruits killmonger eric
stevens
killmonger tony stark's former protege
and killer yeah the watchers eyes narrow
on killer showing the watcher probably
knows he cannot trust killmonger and
it's killmonger's traitor's behavior
that is why the watcher probably needs
him on his team now in vegas thor
wrestles ultron centuries following
ultron's arrival episode seven nobody
messes with vegas
yeah i like how the frame initially pans
over to just show part of the watcher in
the sky as opposed to the clear decisive
reveal shots for all the other recruits
just shows how party thor is super
distracted so the watcher reaches down
to grab him like a toy
you've been chosen
[Applause]
yeah he's still screaming all the way to
his new location just as he does in
ragnarok in the grand master's palace
but more importantly he continues to
clutch that severed ultron century head
which killmonger later uses so you could
argue catching thor off guard just like
this was also part of the watcher's
master plan he needed that head and
killmonger's hand they were transported
to the same pub that peggy and steve got
a drink in episode one thor orders a
beer from doctor strange just like he
gets one from him in ragnarok and then
he chugs and smashes it just as he does
pretty much every drink in his hand
the watcher explains at first i scoured
eternity for one true hero then i saw
the bigger picture this mission requires
a team the perfect combination of skills
and experience that alone will triumph
so the watcher needs more than just one
or even a thousand cosmically powerful
warriors really he needs a specific
ragtag group of underdogs that ultron
would underestimate but also one of whom
would betray the rest and allow the
stones to be sequestered so this isn't a
true dream team it's really a band of
misfits like the guardians of the galaxy
which is why he calls them you are
the guardians of the multiverse so when
thor tries to leave outside the bar is
the swirling storm the pub exterior made
up of doctor strange's eldritch magic
and a clockwork grid i love that
production design here it kind of looks
like strange hid them in a dimension
between realities like the surreal zones
that he zipped through in the dr strange
film same imagery used in the no way
home trailer the golden color palette
does match the portal through which
wanda maximoff saw her future scarlet
witch self i just think this may be the
same kind of setting that multiverse of
madness takes place in familiar
fragments of broken realities
reconstructed amidst a chaotic hellstorm
doctor strange explains six stones of
near unfathomable power each controlling
an essential aspect of our existence yes
it's the same lecture that wong explains
to stark an infinity war big banks and
six elemental crystals these infinity
stones each control an essential aspect
of existence as they discuss the mission
killmonger is almost always staring at
the ultron sentry head now this head is
probably made of vibranium as all the
final form ultrons were which is the
same as killmonger's suit which that hum
that we heard earlier indicated
what do you want with us all good
questions they order chinese takeout
just like the avengers do when
brainstorming the time heist and in-game
and gamora presents the infinity crusher
a device of knitted valyrian design with
gears like a rock grinder the infinity
crusher designed to disintegrate each
stone into nothing now infinity stones
according to the in-game directors
cannot be fully destroyed since infinity
stones are needed to maintain a
universe's proper flow of time but they
can be atomized and prevented from
actual use that's likely what this
crusher does thor says slow down a
little bit there's a few people in the
room that don't understand
not me i i get it but for them maybe
repeat it
you're ready yeah the watcher decides
they're ready in spite of thor's dumb
statement here this shows that he's
actually counting on thor leroy jenkins
into this mission to lure thanos into
underestimating the whole team now if
you stream or podcast or if you want to
sound good when you're gaming the hyperx
quadcast is the ideal standalone
microphone for you the quadcast comes
with anti-vibration shock mount to
reduce the rumbles of daily life and a
built-in pop filter to muffle pesky
plosives the led indicator lets you know
your mic status if it's lit it's live
you can also tap to mute
to avoid awkward broadcasting moments
it's got four selectable polar patterns
that allow you to instantly switch from
settings suited for streaming or music
or a conference call it's got a
convenient gain control dial to quickly
adjust your mic input sensitivity
the quadcast s model has cool looking
rgb lighting and dynamic effects that
are customizable through hyperx
ingenuity software it's super easy to
use and a great looking mic that also
really ups your work zoom game the
quadcast family is compatible with pc
ps5 ps4 and mac as well as major
streaming platforms like obs studio and
xsplit so you sound great to anyone
tuning in so head on over to hyperx dot
gg new rockstars or use the link in this
video's description to grab yourself a
hyperx quadcast mic and start sounding
and looking better doctor strange forms
protection spells for each of them and i
like how each has a different pattern
like there's a five-pointed star a
six-pointed one some sons i assume each
using mysticism from a different
tradition and actually later we see the
five-pointed stars for captain carter as
if her protection is linked with steve
rogers both t'challa and killmonger have
the sun pattern maybe a nod of their
african roots thor gets a series of
squares in a kind of norse runic pattern
and gamora gets the interlaid triangles
with nodes around the circumference
invoking an alien sicarian design and
then the spells coat them like armor
giving thor a winged crown killmonger
and gamora shoulder armor and t'challa
in a crown and an extra layer on his
necklace as he is the rightful king of
wakanda and peggy has some chunky
medieval looking armor for her english
roots strange's squid demon from episode
4 emerges from his hand peggy who later
stares down this beast in the final
battle recognizes this anatomy as some
that she fought in episode 1 perhaps the
same type of elder god being a
schumagura who could show up in
multiverse madness can i ask what
happened
same thing that happened to you strange
gives a toast a wise sorcerer once told
me that to face death is part of the
plan to face death is to conquer one's
greatest fear of the unknown of
nothingless space yeah it sounds like
he's trying to quote the ancient one's
death speech
death is what gives life meaning to know
your days are numbered your time is
short
ultron finds them burst as a giant face
in the sky as the watcher usually does
but way bigger and he arrives through an
interventional portal with that
crystalline texture showing his mastery
now over the multiverse as on par with
watcher now ultron uses a fun
combination of the soul reality and
power stones but not the space stone to
crumble the mountain that they're
standing on i suppose the soul stone in
this case to isolate which souls under
which the ground to warp the reality of
and the power stone to give it all and
hoof the soul stone is just always a
weird one to judge the functionality of
we really just saw it when thanos used
to isolate which strange was the real
one in the wizard dual infinity war
actually strange uses that same images
of icon spell to duplicate mjolnir and
swarm them around ultron strange magics
of peggy's shield to create a mjolnir
plus shield shock wave and then she
hitches a ride back with one of the
mjolnirs the way spider-man did in end
game t'challa grabs ultron and gets
thrown off you can actually see the
moment that he snatches the soul stone
and it's pretty impressive because he
does it with the hand that he's holding
the blaster with strange then unleashes
three demon dragons we actually saw him
absorb two of these in episode four
which i thought was redundant animation
at the time but nope three dragon heads
are better than one strange opens a
portal from the zombie universe the
first ones to fall on ultron are zombie
cap zombie falcon and zombie hawkeye
zombie cap was split down the middle of
his body i guess just don't think about
it thousands more pour out and pile up
but worst among them is zombie wanda
maximoff who should have the power to
break in infinity stone like she did the
mind stone of vision's head infinity war
but she softens briefly maybe because
she recognizes this red synthazoid face
as that of her love vision but ultron
uses this hesitancy to blow up the
freaking planet and as they exit through
the portal the war does a backwards jump
just like peter quill did an infinity
war and they returned to ultron's home
reality on post-apocalyptic earth to
crush the stone from the signs this
actually looks like tokyo peggy needs to
prove to natasha that she knows her your
father is ivan your dars alexi and
you're the one woman i trust to have my
six she uses red skull's genealogy from
end game data of ivan but it's
interesting that peggy would know that
because natasha did not know it but then
yes of course her da being alexi
inaudible alexis shustakov her big dad
with kgb from black widow ultron flips
out why won't she die
wait
what yet good question well it's because
strange still has the power of the time
stone as we see later in this battle
meaning that he could rewind ultron's
explosion the way thanos rewinded wanda
blowing up the mine stone and then
consumed the boom boom the way he did
all of those demons peggy says give him
all you've got don't give him a chance
to think which also tells us a bit about
their strategy right it's not about
beating ultron head to head it's about
overwhelming him so that he cannot
process his next move and like the
avengers dog piling on thanos on titan
we get this awesome long take of each of
them landing their blows on ultron
followed by another long take but just
on the close-up of the soul stone for 11
seconds as people fight over it i love
using the soul stone as a synecdoche for
all of their souls the watcher's soul
the soul of the multiverse this is the
stone that we've seen the least of in
the mcu representing the whole of it in
this battle ultron uses the time stone
to suspend them all in slow motion while
he reclaims the soul stone but strange
uses his own time stone to neutralize
this spell this is the first time we
have seen one infinity stone used
against a variant universe infinity
stone so by dislogic duplicate stones do
retain their power even when they share
a universe but so far i guess when one
is used against the other it just
cancels each other out ultron grows big
and strange allows those demons inside
them to take over which the artists
showed with this amazing effect probably
my favorite shot of the episode the
energy splitting the frame into
different states of being for strange
one layer showing strange the layer
underneath showing his demonic form it's
just a really tactile expression of
strange painfully ripping himself apart
to do this they pin ultron and use the
infinity crusher but uh
every universe is different each one
just a fraction unique
the crusher was designed to destroy the
stones on my world not his yes of course
the framing matches the avengers circle
up shot in the first avengers film and
here this episode establishes yet
another bit of infinity stone rulemaking
while duplicate stones can both function
in a shared universe they can only be
destroyed by something from their same
home universe okay natasha uses the
arrow with zola's ai from episode 8 a
shot that if you think about she only
had because ultron in this moment is
focusing mostly on strange it leaves
some blind spots and i think this is
again part of the watcher's plan to
delay natasha's ace inner hole to the
last minute like this peggy uses the
arrow to take out one of voltron's eyes
and in this moment you can see on the
infinity stones are now glowing somewhat
duller after this point because in
ultron's mind his ultron consciousness
is battling with the zola ai and zola
uses the same kind of snakey neuron bolt
attacks that ultron used to kill jarvis
and i love how those eight strands match
the eight tentacles of the hydra sigil
ultron is dead but killmonger still has
that head with ultron's consciousness
left glowing in it and his vibranium
link allows him control of the reality
stone to assemble his own killmonger
infinity armor
aha that was the fool of flute which
composer ludwig joranson used as
killmonger's unique sound in black
panther peter and the wolf style and
that riff sounded like a real victorious
but also a belligerent blow expressing
killmonger being drunk on power here the
killmonger infinity is challenged i am
afraid that armor belongs to me aha
finally zola's android formed from the
comics with his face in the tummy a
design teased as an easter egg in the
first cap film coming to life and a tug
of war over the stones with this little
ripped in space kind of evoking their
big bang origin i like that touch but
strange realizes we were never meant to
win
we were here to separate the stones from
the bodies and so he creates a pocket
dimension around them trapping them both
you foresaw every moment from the failed
infinity crusher to killmonger's
betrayal and my
your sacrifice yes one wonders how far
back the watchers plan went was it to
his team up with doctor strange or even
before that and with this episode titled
what if the watcher broke his oath we
never really see the consequences of
that broken oath i do plan to explore
the watcher's full plan and his next
steps in a video coming soon they all
return to their home realities but peggy
carter wants to go back to the 40s
haven't i earned my happy ending for
reasons i assume we will see in season 2
since captain carter is confirmed as a
vocal character for this whole series
and will likely be linked with the
rediscovery of steve in the hydrostomper
armor in the post-credits scene
meanwhile black widow he allows to join
the one episode not referenced thus far
in the finale episode three which ended
with nick fury teaming up steve rogers
with carol danvers to fight loki's
takeover of earth this shield
helicarrier is numbered 64 the same
number from the first avengers film and
this could provide one way natasha
romanov could ever return in live action
especially now that scarlett johansson
has wonderfully settled her legal
troubles with disney thanks to millions
of dollars in a payout and we're left
with the watcher saying every story is
my home
and i will protect it to the end
just like he said to natasha your
stories
they
are everything to me i love this because
yes while we have seen the watcher as a
kind of creepy voyeuristic figure his
sudden vulnerability here gives us
permission to have emotional attachments
to the stories that we watch yeah it's
okay to see pieces of ourselves and the
wins and losses of our heroes because
why are any of us here if not to stir
something inside of each other and with
that i want to thank you all so much for
playing watcher to this whole season of
coverage of marvel's what if these
breakdowns and our inside marvel after
shows it's just been a delight unpacking
it all together trying to keep up with
its elusive infinity stone logic and if
you want to support us the best way to
do it is by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com you can
follow me on instagram and twitter
eaboss follow and subscribe to new
rockstars thanks again for watching bye
[Music]
you